I heard yesterday
um
after I did that podcast with Adam
sosnick that uh Andrew and Tristan got
another 30 days to the end of uh
February and they still haven't charged
them with anything do you have any
updates from within Romania dragos
um
that there's something happening in the
background in the sense that usually
when they extend the arrest
um they probably have more evidence or
they're in the process of um creating it
that's the key word yeah
um a lot of the people or some of the
people that were presented as victims
have um come out to support Andrew they
have um explained how their testimony
was not taken into account like the the
prosecutor just threw the paper away
when it wasn't incriminating against
Tate it seems like the like there's some
Western media behind this because I was
watching a a translated Romanian
broadcast and yeah and the gal was on
clearly a Romanian air TV show but the
ticker Banner on the bottom was CNN
yeah right and the and the translation
wasn't wasn't favorable but it's just
you know it's just
it's
um it's ongoing but the media is so
biased the mainstream media is so biased
against him and even some of the local
uh TV uh stations that were less
political have gotten on the bandwagon
and they're basically recycling the same
news like the one where they said that
he was um trying to get underage girls
to to work for him
the reality is that he just Preston sent
some tricks the message that they're
beautiful this is what God presented as
trying to get them to work for them
right so they're taking the same news
old news right this was on the news
years ago and they're recycling it and
every single day they are finding a
different thing to say negatively about
them and it's so painfully obvious like
I've talked to my dad and I'm like we're
sitting drinking a beer and I'm asking
him one evening like what do you think
about this and he's like I don't know
what cool this guy pissed off but it's
so obvious they're against him like it's
right you can see it from the [__]
airplane yeah so apparently the schools
are trying to like re-educate kids now
uh especially teenage boys to like stop
them from adopting his uh ideas stuff
that he's broadcasted so I got this clip
over here I think we should play and
sort of touch on because I don't know
who this chick is but basically you know
she's saying that teenage boys are
generally idiots and teenage girls are
really something to behold and uh
brilliant so let me just uh hit play
here let me know if you guys can't hear
it if you wrote a piece on Spike this
week about Andrew Tate and the reaction
to Andrew Tate and it got me thinking
because I was speaking to it
oh come on
freaking Spinning Wheel of death let's
go baby the stream yard issue isn't it I
think I think it's a stream yard issue
it it usually happens only on stream
yard
I don't know what that is
here let me just hit refresh and see if
it'll reload and we'll try it one more
time so teenage boys are going to listen
to this chick that's what I'm thinking
yeah right Andrew Tate and it got me
thinking because I was speaking to a
teacher friend of mine who said that at
his school there was a decree that came
down from the Headmaster saying that uh
this the name must not be mentioned
among the children because it will
radicalize them into misogyny is that
the right way to deal with this
apparently according to your article
this is happening quite a lot in schools
yeah well some there are there was this
big article in the times education
supplement which was all about how to
instruct teachers how to deal with
Andrew Tate and the influence of Andrew
Tay
um and one of the main things was
calling for official CPD training for
all schools to be able to deal with
Andrew takes number one you know truth
that's forever thus is that 13 year old
boys which is sort of the main kind of
age category that is finds him
interesting are generally idiots I mean
you know they're they're like in the
nicest way possible they're very
immature they you know pick up on stuff
they get obsessed there's a reason why
so many of them are obsessed with gaming
and things like that they're obsessed
with things you're sort of arguing and
correct me if I'm wrong but a
victim-centered feminism or a feminism
that says yes women are weaker and need
more protection that's the wrong way to
go about this yeah it's because well
number one it's just not true there is
nothing more terrifying and Brilliant
than a teenage girl I mean really they
are they're something to behold and
obviously
[Laughter]
and they wonder why boys like Tate right
did she just skip that that decade I
don't know teenagers in general yeah
most of them are idiots but I don't know
I mean yeah they're just kind of yeah
things which will now for [__] sakes
let me just hit refresh one more time
hopefully we can get through to the end
2008 and it got me dpd training all you
need is a teacher with a confidence
sense of who he really might be and so I
think that he should be talked about in
schools we don't need CPD training all
you need is a teacher with the
confidence to say what about this loser
interests you and do you know what what
about him do you think is going to make
you successful and just have a
conversation in reality rather than
write seven articles about how
terrifying he is and you know uh want to
it's also not a kind of coincidence I
think that this whole Panic is happening
at the same time that for example lots
of politicians are going absolutely
mental about the Online safety bill at
the moment and there's this kind of
there's a snowballing effect of young
people are being brainwashed by people
online really all we have to do is pull
the plug and give them a bit of a kick
intellectually and maybe physically and
say get interested in something real
because you wrote a piece on well
imagine you're a teacher uh in the
United Kingdom
I don't know what they would pay them
probably 35 45 000 pound a year
I don't know where's uh 50 maybe maybe
he'll pop in soon we can ask him but
imagine standing there and going why are
you listening to this loser
it's so interesting how the low-income
teacher because I really interesting
most of my teachers were losers my bad
go ahead no she's sitting here saying
like oh let's have a real conversation
let's have an odd conversation she
prefaces it by this loser it's like what
the [__] is that it's like hey hey why
are you listening to this idiot that's
not I mean
it's just everything is just so ass
backwards with this entire thing I mean
when you want to talk about what's going
on over here with
Global Elites uh flying to a sex Island
and not a single one of them ever seen
inside of a jail cell or a courtroom
when you want to talk about the
brainwashing of young children when
we're seeing all of these Rainbow
Warriors uh meanwhile you have two men
that have that that were sex trafficking
uh two boys aged I think under 11 years
old
um not only
yes not only for their own personal use
so to speak but also pipping them out to
other neighbors
um I mean and this is what we choose to
demonize and this is what we're focused
on I mean the entire world is just
backwards and I want it to burn I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out